like at first when you start listening
to red pill like um there's like phases
as a girl first there's like
shock a little bit because they're
talking about how it's over basically
when you hit 30
and
and we might be homeless
and all these all these stats that like
oh i'm like oh my god no
i'm like
and then like at 25 i'm like i peaked
two years ago
actually i kind of knew that i feel like
most people peak in high school actually
and just personal opinion because i feel
like most people gain weight in college
yeah
yeah like
um but
like you get all these numbers but then
you just start to like see the world
differently and just realize how society
caters and favors women
almost at the expense of men yeah and
like once you see it like once you start
like looking at the world through this
lens you start to
flip situations like when a girl says
something you say it from like the guy's
point of view and you think would that
be okay and like 90 of the time it's no
it's so weird
and
it's like you can't go back once you see
it
and just the same way that men can't go
back once they realize women don't like
nice guys yeah yeah
that's true
it's true because
have you ever tried to you know do any
of the guys know girls who were really
into like the idea of the [ __ ] walk
right and then uh because i knew girls
who had boyfriends and they they were a
part of that they really want to be a
part of it and the boyfriend i asked her
it's like all right cool if you're going
to do the slot work where you're
you're basically got your whole body out
can i go to work in my underwear
she said no it's like why
where's the broke man walk
exactly um you see what the what if
there is broken demanding women like
them that's what [ __ ] are doing they're
demanding men like them
imagine
where's the grey sweatpants walk
[Laughter]
run that one yeah
where's the short man walk
but that's what all these movements are
they're shaming men into liking them the
ageism
yeah that's shaming men saying like me
and and like oh single dating in my 30s
is the best even though 50 of your
options are gone by 30. like
i know see these facts aren't fun
[Laughter]
and um
yeah fat phobic so when a guy when a guy
like says oh you know what i like skinny
girls then he's fat phobic or if a guy
says you know what i don't date single
moms i don't want to raise no one else's
kid then he's the bad guy it's like all
of these things are shaming men
and even even when kevin samuel said
leftover women
i mean what else is there those are the
women that are left over
[Music]
i'm not
it's just i'm not saying
i'm not saying every girl over 30 is
like it's over for her but what i am
saying is that if you found a man in
your 20s that you wanted to marry you
would be married so the men that you
want to marry don't want you
tough and so like if you're single and
i'm single right this isn't that means
for some reason the men that you want
don't want you
or you don't know where to find them and
you haven't put in the effort to find
them
i mean how many girls have really
researched
if they want a guy in a certain income
bracket what cities they live in where
do they hang out
oh yeah
yeah like
that about stuff like that gotta do some
research
she's
[Laughter]
three
it's crazy because um i think the [ __ ]
walk
me personally i think slot walkers when
women officially stopped
listening to what men think what they
care like what they care about if they
care
and whatnot and i think
i think that movement kind of
put a stamp on when men can't speak for
women normally yeah for me personally
because it's like
if they cared then um
they would have probably probably would
have done it
you understand like you're saying about
your friend's girl and whatnot yeah yeah
did she end up going
i don't even know that about that story
but you told me i was like oh that's
crazy
if she did end up there and then she
probably belonged to history so
probably belongs to the streets because
it's like [ __ ] walk fine but it's there
gang banger walk say a road my walk i
want to be a road man i just wanna i'm
not actually road when i'm actually
i wear glasses and i work in offices
yeah i mean i guess
like it's like advocating for knife
crime and being like if you don't also
advocate for knife crime with me you're
a bad guy it's like no knife crime is
bad
do you think we should take a book out
of like
muslim culture
yes where girls cover themselves i think
i personally think that's where it's
gonna headed to because i think girls
have taken off their clothes so much the
only direction to go is put on your
clothes i didn't it's gonna go to a
level where
i think the muslim culture has a lot of
obviously they have their own issues but
they have a lot of like it's a lot of
it's based in well from the outside
looking in like it's based a lot in like
having a mutual somewhat respect for
each other
even if that respect might come from an
authoritarian standpoint it's still like
having the respect to like do or be what
your partner
wants you and needs you to be
like outside of religion obviously they
have their own the things that they have
to follow right and having those sets of
rules are also great because it gives
you a sense of sense of purpose and
there's a question i was going to ask oh
that was going to do do you think people
are really into zodiac signs now because
they're becoming less religious as a
whole and they want to find some sort of
higher purpose women that um believe in
zodiac people that believe in zodiac
sign
um have higher narcissistic traits
fun facts yeah yeah i can see that
because
have you read every horoscope in a day
and
like if you if you read a horoscope read
all of them and you know and see which
ones don't apply to you
it's easier to count the ones that don't
apply than the ones that do yeah because
there's like maybe one or two that might
not apply
but the rest of them are just like vague
it's like
you're going to put your shoe your shoes
on left foot first it's like okay guys
so much
wow
wow
but i think you're right i think you are
right though i think the
zodiacs and stuff like that is it's uh
because because yeah because the world's
becoming like further away from god
like they look for like a replacement
yeah
because
basically the reason that that came to
my mind is to go back to your like point
of like should we move to the muslim
faith and i'm like i think people have
really started to find their own
quote-unquote religion with zodiacs
which is why i don't think it can really
go to the whole putting clothes on
because everyone how how long do you
think it's going to be between till now
zodiac's becoming an actual religion
there's a spaghetti religion
the thing is that zodiac is it aligns
with what you actually want to hear yeah
of course yeah like they give you what
you actually want to
consume you want you want to hear like
all the positive things about yourself
even if you're in the wrong place yeah
if there was a zodiac church how many
people do you think go
you know you know what i think the new
religion is for women
selfish
me me me me um
everything's about me what are zodiacs
about me
why why should you leave a divorce for
me i want to be happy me
i'm my happiness is more important than
my kids happiness me
like that's that's perfectly acceptable
to say nowadays
you think about how selfish that is
crazy when like every time i went on a
podcast and this clip went viral because
i said if i have kids and i'm married
and i'm not happy
i will stay because my kid's happiness
is more important than my own yes
and
to me that's just common sense like if
i'm a mother like i would hope i love
the kids more than myself
but modern women don't they love
themselves
why do you what do you think i've heard
of so many girls saying their moms used
to compete with them
yeah and get jealous and
and even a lot of numbers suggest that
men are better single fathers than
single mothers and they put the kids
especially financially they're much
better with their money
and yet women win them in custody
battles
when it's not it's not apparent that
they're better parents
because of the maternal instinct which
goes i was literally thinking this on a
train today
that a lot of people forget that men
love their kids too and that's really
weird
that's really strange
men are better parents over the age of
like seven yeah because because women
were chemically different every single
day like we all know whose mom was moody
at times
and honestly a lot of people i talked to
if i said would you rather if your
parents got divorced would you rather
live with your mom or your dad a lot of
people that i've talked to would say dad
hmm
[Music]
it's true
yeah cause even though the dad gives the
quote-unquote tough love that everyone
wants to be oh you're so heartless but
the advice given to you by your dad a
lot of times is the advice that you
probably need to hear the most because
it's like he's coming from a place of
you know you have to if you want to be
successful you have to do this well the
mom's coming from a place of if you want
to be happy you have to do this
and that's like the girl's new religion
is selfish and happy yeah i think i
think that dad's advice will keep you
out of joel 100.
and uh maybe for a girl keep you off the
stripper poles i like that i'll keep you
off the streets
so um
you know
like i think you're right i think that
that does come has to come in the
later stages of
a child's life
another phrase i'm a 10.
no i'm serious what is that that's me
that's selfish that's that's narcissism
i am the table
yeah
it's like narcissism is women's new
religion that's a better word for it
narcissism is women's new religion
the phrase i am the table makes me laugh
because every time i someone says that
to me i was like you know what you
should do change the word table to
relationship and see if that makes sense
to you
i am the relationship that's so that's a
that's a good one
[Laughter]
change the word from table to
relationship and see if that makes sense
to you i am the relationship no you know
no no no no this is a mutual thing or it
should be at least and then we feminine
feminism feminizes men too
even even when we advocate for men we do
it selfishly because we want them to be
more emotionally available for us
so even even like the men didn't say we
want to be more emotionally available
like you know i never i bring men on the
tie all the time on my show i've never
heard a guy say i want to be more
emotionally available it's the girls
saying i want them to be more
emotionally available so even when
they're advocating for men it's still
about
women
but they'll say that but they'll say
it'll be good for us yeah it's good for
you
[Laughter]
and then you do it and we leave
we're like oh not that emotionally
available in front of me again
they want it but with stipulations if
you don't bring the
what they want wrapped up how they want
it then it'll be like i went like that i
want that but
let me tell you how i want it so you can
give it to me how i want it and it's not
natural and usually guys will just not
do it yeah
if you're giving me anything with
separations i'm just not gonna do it
doing it like
i'm not doing it
again that's some guys a lot a lot of
guys out here might just fold and bend
the wheel and that's because like those
are the ones that are not getting
they're not getting any you know guys
are like that sounds too complicated i'm
just gonna do it worse
yeah and that goes along with
women guys wanting women to be their
piece
and
wanting them to feel calm around them if
there's too many stipulations and all
these boxes they gotta check before they
walk through the front door it's like
that's tired you're already tired before
you
interact with her
[Music]
tired from fighting everyone in the
world coming your house and i'm still
fighting so fine
can i sleep
and that's when i
started listening to manosphere content
and they started talking about like what
men want it's so easy compared to what
women want they just want a girl that's
fit
feminine and friendly
and yet we still complain
that men are too picky even though they
swipe right 50 of the time on dating
apps where women swipe right
between 5 and 20 depending on the study
but they're the two picky ones and every
time i talk to them they're like men
they want the kim kardashian hourglass
shape and the guys are like just not
obese please
that's pretty that's not a whale
not a whale
and girls are like fat phobic and
they're like look
i mean 35 and under please and they're
like you're ageist
i just i want a girl that can give me
kids ageism